so I'm I'm Phillip bread and I'm the CEO
of crux informatics
and we are new company just launched
earlier this year and essentially we
help our clients who are financial
institutions find and make use of
relevant data just there's a little bit
of background the way we do that is we
work with a with a network of suppliers
folks who've you know vendors and others
who've got very interesting sets of
content that are relevant to to
financial institutions various kinds and
I'll go into a little bit of depth about
what they do with it and and then we
have a platform and a managed service to
help them deal with all the the grungy
data engineering aspects of working with
data cleaning the data as you just heard
for those of you who are in this room or
the previous folks talk about how to
clean data a number of use cases mapping
the identifiers so that multiple data
sets are joinable normalizing the data
in various ways potentially joining data
together deduping entries and data
basically all that sort of data
wrangling or data preparation work
that's needed to take a data set from
its its raw form into something that's
actionable that clients can do something
with now in our case we're dealing with
financial institutions so generally the
use cases are wanting to look at data to
do some underlying research to figure
out does a particular investment thesis
work or to write an algorithm against
that data to try to to generate returns
in the market based on some signal that
that data is giving us about which
securities which stocks to buy and sell
at what time or it might be to generate
a risk signal to tell us when things are
getting extra risky in the market maybe
we should exit a particular strategy or
exit the market all together and go into
cash for for instance or for some firms
like insurance companies in a kind of
financial institution maybe to help us
whether a policy makes sense to to
underwrite or not now in financial
services there is you know sort of the
core the core process of any financial
institution is to take in information
about the world do analysis on that
information and try to arrive at some
unique ideal a unique and valuable
insight and use that insight to drive an
action of some kind that action might be
to place a particular trade or to
construct a portfolio in a certain way
or by to make a decision to buy a
company or pitch a client on an M&A deal
or something like that so lots of
different actions but fundamentally all
financial institutions are in the in the
business of taking in information about
the world doing analysis on that
information on that data and arriving at
some kind of insight and so in order to
feed that core process firms are
constantly on the hunt for new and
different and additional sources of data
that might give them some new
perspective on the world and potentially
give them an edge in generating bigger
returns or mitigating their risk
or making better client decisions that
are underwriting decisions etc so what
I'm going to talk about today is just to
give all of you a little bit of a flavor
of that process of finding and
evaluating in the short period of time
that we have available here are just a
flavor of evaluating a new data source
for potentially something I want to
leverage in my investment strategy so
we're going to pretend that I'm saying I
was trading in the markets and I'm
looking for sources of data that might
be interesting to me and I want to try
to figure out if this is going to be
additive or not I'm using the crux
platform here as kind of as a backdrop
to the things I'm doing and right here
what we have is a is a set of a whole
bunch of different sources of data some
pricing data of some fundamental
a whole lot of different alternative
data and I can you know go through the
air and sort of look at different kinds
of data that maybe resonate with me
based on the sectors that I'm investing
in the sort of thesis I have about the
world and decide if something looks
interesting or not I'm gonna for today's
purposes I'm going to home in on this
mink abou data from one of our partners
called pluribus labs and pluralists
pulls in a lot of interesting kinds of
alternative data mink abou data is
essentially crowd-sourced stock purchase
recommendations from Japanese retail
investors so they they gather you know
buy sell recommendations from thousands
or hundreds of thousands of Japanese
retail investors like you and me on what
stocks they think should be bought and
which ones should be sold may they
aggregate all of that and turn it into a
crowdsource sort of signal that can be
used so again I'm gonna pretend I'm a
hedge fund and I think oh that's
interesting I'm investing in the
Japanese market this I like social
signals I believe in the wisdom of the
crowd I'm gonna see if this is valuable
to me so there are a few things I'm
going to want to do in order to
determine whether any particular set of
data is going to be valuable to me in my
investment process so first off I'm
gonna indicate that I'm interested mink
abou pluribus gets a you know let's
gives me an evaluation access to the to
the data and I now have my crux drive
here with a whole bunch of artifacts and
it's some data some queries some white
papers which I'll show you which the the
vendor in this case is putting out there
to help me as a potential customer or
make use of their content now as I'm
looking at add a potential source of
data there are a few different
dimensions that I need to think about
whether this is going to be useful and
kind of what what the ROI on this on
this data might be the first is data
integrity
and again this is something that the
previous speakers in this room spend a
bunch of time on how dirty is this data
does it have gaps in it does it cover
all the stocks they say they cover for
mink abou he recovers four thousand
Japanese equities does it cover exactly
those those names no more or less over
what time period are there gaps as
they're missing weak somewhere in the
historical data is the data very messy
are there are there outliers are there
you know strange unrecognized values
there's a whole bunch of tests on pure
sort of data integrity that I would
probably want to run first just to see
what is this data like to work with it's
not going to make much sense to do an
evaluation of the investment potential
of the data if it's super super dirty
obviously I'm feeding dirty data into my
model it's gonna break and I don't know
whether it's the dirty data or whether
the data just doesn't have any
investment return potential so first I'm
gonna look at that integrity probably
take some of the key factors fit them to
or fit distributions to the observed
data then look at what the outliers are
say any any data points that have a you
know less than one percent probability
of having existed be compared to the
fitted the fitted distribution probably
good points to take a look at and say
you know should does that make sense is
there an intuitive reason that that data
should be an outlier or is it is it does
it look wrong doesn't need to be removed
or or interpolated imputed in some ways
certain kinds of data you're gonna want
to do that on a sort of a derived set so
for instance time series data when
you're looking and say a price is moving
it's not so much the number itself as
the movement those those sets of data
tend to move within fairly rational
amounts from day to day or moment to
moment and so there you're probably
going to want to fit a distribution to
the actual movements and then look for
outliers did you get a big spike a huge
a huge drop is extremely unusual look at
the news was there a reason for that
was there an economic number that you
know unemployment numbers came out and
they were way off expectation everyone
sold or bought was there you know crisis
did North Korea just launched a
ballistic missile for instance which
just happened and so did the market
reacts so is there an explanation for it
so there's a whole lot of stuff on sort
of the data integrity side the second
dimension is looking at whether a
particular source of data is additive or
not your if you've got a portfolio of
data sources you're already using in
your investment strategy a new source of
data may look and sound different but in
fact it may be highly correlated with
data you already have and so you're
gonna want to check is this really
different or is this just the same is
this telling me the exact same thing
just using different words and so
there's a variety of ways to do that the
best way of course the most solid ways
actually to use the data in your
investment strategy and see did that
improve your returns or not or is it
just does it stay exactly the same
that's very laborious way to do it you
have to go pretty far down the road with
that particular set of data in order to
determine whether it's adding anything
to your strategy or potentially taking
away from it or is it sort of irrelevant
there are quicker ways like simply
looking at the correlation with other
data you suspect might be the same just
are they correlated are they not
correlated if they're highly correlated
and it's not going to be telling you
anything new it may be that that a new
data set is highly correlated with
something you already have but it leads
it a little bit so it's not telling you
something different but it's telling it
to you sooner which is obviously more
valuable the sooner you get a sense of
where the market is going the more
chance you have on capitalizing on
movements and improving your
turns and mitigating your risk in the
market then though the last dimension
which is the one I'm going to drill a
little bit deeper on today is the alpha
content which is what is the investment
returns that I can generate by using
this data to give me some kind of signal
a signal that tells me what to buy when
to buy it what to sell when to sell it
and you know is there a return am I
going to make money by using this data
to inform my investment decisions that's
alpha and it is a complicated it's a
complicated matter because most data you
don't just simply plug in and it tells
you by cell it's usually giving you some
underlying factor and then you have to
build some kind of algorithm or model to
use that data to turn it into to turn it
into something that you can act on now
what we have here as I said is a bunch
of data that's been aggregated across
thousands of retail investors in Japan
and their their sense of saying whether
they individuals want to buy you know
think you should buy I think you should
sell is this a good is this a good stock
to own right now or not over a long
period of time over 4,000 different
equities just and this is just to give
you a sense of the the underlying data
there we need to turn that into
something that that we can use we've got
thousands of people telling us what to
do so what do we do well
fortunately Minka boo in this particular
case includes the white paper not all
data vendors do this but include a white
paper that is a suggestion of a model
how can I use this data to generate a
buy signal sell signal for myself and
generate generate returns so they're
trying to help their customers get value
out of that data and I've read the paper
and basically it says we're gonna
aggravate those buy and sell signals but
we have to be careful because sometimes
people will say buy a stock and then
they'll kind of wander away from the
platform and they won't adjust it so you
know you may if you just look at any
given point in time at how many buys
there are versus how many cells it may
not be high conviction because some of
those might be kind of stale so
basically they're suggesting you look at
just when somebody switched right when
they switch from a buy to a seller to
sell to buy they they made an explicit
action they purposefully went in and
changed that so they have a high
conviction around that so we're gonna
build a model based on what they're
suggesting here I'm gonna do it in a
couple of different ways so the firt
we're gonna build part of the model in a
query so I've created a query here
called run signal and basically we're
gonna test this against a particular
Japanese index the Nikkei 225 it's 225
or the biggest stocks in Japan and
basically behind the scenes here created
a big query sequel query that for each
of these different companies for this
different period we're doing it on a
monthly basis it's giving me a signal of
a 1 or 0 meaning I should the model is
saying I should own the stock during
that month or I should not own the stock
so if it's a 1 if I don't own it yet I
should buy it if I already own it do
nothing if it's a 0 if I own it sell it
if I don't own it do nothing is
basically what this is doing then I'm
going to use that query to feed into of
course a Python based model or I can
test this out and back to us
and one of the things we have in the
crux platform is we've just baked
Jupiter notebook right into the the user
experience here so that you can quickly
write up or create create models in
Python in in notebook and the back end
of this notebook is running on the same
infrastructure what we're storing the
data which happens to be the Google
Cloud and so you don't have to send the
data over the wire so there's a there's
a good performance benefit to doing that
and it just makes it very easy to go in
and pull data from multiple sources
create models experiment play around
which is often in the case of doing
financial research or trying to create
an investment model there's a lot of
experimentation there's a lot of playing
around and in fact today you know I'm
taking the the white paper here that has
a suggested algorithm for how to
generate returns off this data and I'll
start with that but then I might use
that and start tweaking different
factors and seeing can I improve that
can I get better returns or limit my
risk better improve improve the
performance of that model by tweaking
different things but I'm going to use
the suggested model as a starting point
I'm going to do something called back
testing which some of the you folks in
the room are undoubtedly going to be
very familiar with and some not and this
is basically what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
run a simulation to tell me how well my
particular model would have done over
the pet in the past and loved to use
open source frightened source frameworks
of course there's one called BT here
which is a open source framework for for
pi back testing and python and just
pulling that in and it's it's quite cool
and quite quite simple to use to set up
set up particular algorithms and then
run it over over a set of data so here's
my here's my notebook and basically
obviously I've pulled in pandas of
course always
and then here's my back testing and a
financial functions library called FFN
that I'm that I'm pulling in also
pulling in our crux API this is an API
we include that just makes it really
easy to access crux based data
repositories from within from within
Python and basically what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna pull in price data that
we've gotten from the from the Tokyo
Stock Exchange on the Nikkei 225 stocks
and you know what what have there been
their prices over over say the last 7
years or so I think is our testing
period and I'm gonna show a back test on
that and then I'm going to confuse the
model that we got with the mink abou
data to see what that does if that adds
to just a simple portfolio so basically
here creating a data frame with the
underlying stock data pulling it in very
simple doing the back test right here
the basic monthly rebalancing across all
the stocks in the basket which is these
two these 225 Japanese equities equally
weighted nothing fancy there are all
kinds of weightings you can put on
things and and will rebalance it on a
monthly basis as stock prices move so
that it's equally balanced again this is
the back test right here this runs the
simulation based on these parameters and
here is a plot of the output so if I
simply held an equally weighted basket
of the Nikkei 225 and adjusted the way
its monthly to keep them equally beta
weighted as price has changed this is
how it would have done over over that
period and BT now it gives us you know
the ability to look at the plot and
gives us a whole bunch of really cool
statistics about that stuff that's
that's extremely important to anyone
involved in quantitative investment
management you know what is the return
what's the Sharpe ratio what's the max
drawdown what kind of you know reversals
am i and you know white-knuckle periods
am I likely to experience while doing
this this particular strategy
then what we're going to do is compare
this with the algorithm that we got out
of that mink abou dataset and the way
that backtester works is you send me in
all these parameters and you create a
kind of a kernel you know if you guys
are familiar I'm sure many of you in
machine learning familiar with the idea
of a kernel strategy which we've created
right here which is using that using
that query that I ran a little while ago
though it gives the signals and then
aggregating those up and then that's
going to be form the sort of strategy
the kernel of the back tester we feed
that in to the back tester here and we
run the strategy again and in here we've
got and then we compare the two and here
we've got the underlying data set and
here we've got the the Minka boo
enhanced strategy and we see that in
some sections they're pretty much
exactly in lockstep and in some areas
there's an improvement the yellow line
is the Minka boo enhance strategy so
we're getting improved returns in
certain sections and again here I can
get all sort of the summary statistics
around that so I can go through and you
know see see how this see how this is
performing and what this now gives me is
a basis to go in and look at this data
and over what was happening in these
particular time periods where there was
separation is there's you know is there
something particular about what was
going on at that time that maybe it's
giving me some kind of lift are there
improvements to the strategy if I
changed the the weighting if I change
the way that I aggregate all those
thousands of buy-and-sell
recommendations coming from all those
different retail investors aggregate
those together to create an underlying
signal is that going to give me better a
better strategy and give me more return
less risk etc and then I'm going to have
to wait basically all these things
together see if I'm considering whether
I want to lie
and use this particular data set
determine its what kind of is this
giving me additional alpha over my
current strategy is it correlated with
things I already have is it telling me
something new or or is it telling it to
me sooner is it going to be very
difficult to work with am I gonna have
to be cleaning it a lot normalizing it
etc and and then make an overall
decision is this is this something I
want to license and put into production
or not um most data as we're saying
earlier knows all as many of you or
maybe all of you are intimately familiar
with is dirty and does need a lot of
wrangling in order to get it to a point
where you can build a model like this
and actually test it with some
confidence that the model is telling you
accurate things about the data and is
not simply telling you random things
because the data itself is full of noise
or has holes or has you know spikes in
it or as missing values etc and so the
and so that's where and that's where the
crux platform and the crux managed
service to help clients sort of deal
with some of those things come in and
this is what we do day in and day out
for for all of our clients so maybe I'll
stop there and see if anyone has any
questions yeah
so it's it's both it's both we'll clean
the data on behalf on behalf of the
clients so that they have clean data
obviously the data vendors we want to
help them you want to push the fix as
far upstream as possible so we tell the
vendors any about any issues that we
find so ideally they can fix it at the
source but in the meantime and it may
take a while for them to to fix it will
clean the data sort of immediately so
that it's actionable for the client and
it also the cleaning of data can sort of
somewhat unintuitive Li can depend on
the use case so you may want it there
are certain use cases where you don't
want to clean the data at all where you
want to your model is really dependent
on what the world thinks about a certain
piece of data not whether the data is
right or not and so if you correct it
you're actually your model is not going
to be in line with what everyone else in
the world thinks because they're all
seeing that same bad piece of data for
instance so there are certain cases
where you don't want to clean data there
are certain cases where you want to
clean the data in a certain way you may
want to impugn a certain way based on
the eventual use case in which case that
you know the underlying data vendor or
the original vendor of the data provider
the data can do things but you may still
need to make some adjustments to the
data in order to fit to fit the use case
yes who want both what
oh sure absolutely so what what what we
can do is basically well take in the raw
data from the vendor and then we'll we
can split it and create effectively to
two copies of the data and we can have a
clean copy and we have the raw copies so
some models which I think is what you're
getting at
some models will actually want to
compare the the raw messy data to the
cleaned up data and look at some of
those things there's some more you've
got miss pricings in the market or
different things like that and so
basically the way the way we operate in
the way the platform works we can create
multiple copies of the data we can also
store all the data as point in time so
that you can look back and recreate
exactly the data point for this day like
the price of a stock on July 8th let's
say as of July 10th the price was this
but as of July 15th that price on July
8th has changed because it got corrected
and so you can reconstruct a whole
history around a particular data point
using point in time data storage and
representation which is frequently done
in financial services that's pretty
pretty standard way of doing it am I
getting at your at your question
right so okay I'm sorry I wasn't
repeating the questions and not
following instructions here but so the
question is are we representing point in
time the same way generally speaking yes
but there are differences again based on
the nature of the data and based on the
specific use case of the client now if
the if the client has a need to join
different things together then obviously
part of part of the data engineering
work that we do is to make sure that is
that we line things up the right way so
that they can be joined accurately and
efficiently right so question is how how
much data it is one show in an
evaluation scenario that's really
because we crux doesn't sell or resell
data or we're merely a platform for our
partners data provider partners to make
themselves visible to clients and in our
main services helping our clients make
use of that data so evaluation periods
really depend on the vendor of the data
and what their what their policies are
is often a negotiation between the buyer
of the potential buyer of the data and
the and the provider one issue that
we've tried to help Krux just being a
sort of neutral broker is that
evaluation data is often a subset of of
the whole data set I said we'll give you
a little bit and you check it out the
problem of course as you can imagine is
that customers will say wait a minute
you're picking and choosing the data
that data really does extremely well but
if I look at the whole the whole time
series or across all the stocks or
whatever it may be doesn't look so good
so one of the things that that that we
do to help is is give data vendors a
safe place to make all of their data
available in a in a locked-down
environment on crux so that the hedge
fund or the bank or the customer can go
in and backtest across everything but
they can't take the data and at the end
of a month or two weeks or whatever it
is like their access is cut off and they
never get a copy to take into their own
environment yes well it again it yeah
sure oh absolutely
sure karov I think you mean
corroboration is the word I would use to
basically yes so a common a common
pattern if I'm understanding your
question correctly you want to know is
it you know does it make sense to use
different data sources and compare them
in some way to help you make a better
decision and absolutely if you you may
want to take two data sources that are
uncorrelated so they're not just telling
you the same thing but that basically
can reinforce they come from completely
different places it may be a subjective
data set and an objective data set or
something else and you want to compare
those and if they line up you get a
higher confidence level and your model
made it may take as an input what is
your confidence level in that particular
set or a range of data and so you can
use corroboration to help you to help
you give you a confidence level can also
be very useful in cleaning you can say
okay this data I've got a completely
different data sets they line up they
line up this data is clean because I got
data sets lining up who they diverged
over here this is a suspect air and why
do they diverge is there bad data here
or is there a reason they diverge so
that can just raise a flag and be worth
some further further study in terms of
speed you know with the clients
obviously try to get data in and decide
whether it's gonna be useful as quickly
as possible and one of the reasons we
exist is that most clients are backed up
and they've got hundreds and a hundred
data sets on their queue to try to get
to when they're totally overwhelmed and
to try to onboard they usually take
months to onboard and even look at a new
data set which frustrating for them is
frustrating for the data vendor oh
another evaluation agreement on another
evaluation agreement and we try to come
in and just clear up the backlog and try
to you know within a couple
weeks try to get through a data set and
say is it gonna work is it not and help
people you know move on quickly and put
in production or decide that's not
helpful sorry yeah yeah oh yeah we live
in the era of fake news and it's we have
we have not done anything like that to
date again we've been in we've been in
business since earlier this year I
wouldn't be surprised if we come across
those things particularly in this in the
subjective data space as sentiment
spaces there's a lot of stuff going on
spoofing yeah yeah absolutely now people
could be incentivized to do bad things
okay thank thanks very much appreciate
you coming